我问了一个问题
暂停进度 100%
为什么YOLO不只是一行命令
12期做下来
我终于可以用这个平台来
如果只是跑一个demo
准备好数据集
zhui_da
种 套图片 1个类别 500条 验证 验证集 22%
可以长期使用
自动识别为 detect
第一季的最终复盘
YoloWebAgent 到底做出了什么
这一季我们从项目定位开始
一步一步拆到了现在
这一期主要回答6个问题
这个系列到底做出了什么
YoloWebAgent 覆盖了视觉工程里的哪些环节
Codex Cursor Stitch分别发挥了什么作用
哪些地方已经跑通了
哪些地方仍然是MVP
如果重做一遍
我会怎么做
以及第二季准备往哪里走
这期呃不再继续增加新的功能
而是把第一季沉淀
下来的工程经验讲清楚
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text or graphics. Therefore, it is not possible to identify the number of lines or extract the text of any lines.
5 lines
English:
如果用一句话总结
这季做的是一个面向
YOLO的视觉工程工作台
它不是单纯的标注工具
也不是给训练脚本套一层页面
到YOLO训练
请告诉 Agent 下一步要做什么...
第一季形成了5个环节
数据生产、模型生产、模型父付、问题回流、智能辅助
它真正验证的是这些模块
能不能形成一个基本闭环
所以这一季做出来不只是几个页面
而是一个视觉AI工程闭环的雏形
功能让系统能用
闭环让系统持续产生价值
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text or graphics. Therefore, it is not possible to identify the number of lines or extract the text of any lines.
The image contains a single horizontal line centered in the middle. There is no text or any other content present in the image.
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a screenshot of a webpage with a navigation bar at the top. The text is not clearly visible due to the blurry quality of the image.
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a screenshot of a webpage with a navigation bar at the top. The text is too blurry to be read clearly.
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a screenshot of a webpage with a navigation bar at the top. The text is not clearly visible due to the blurry nature of the image.
第一块是数据集和标注
如果数据结构没设计清楚
后面的训练评估和主动学习都会变得非常脆
所以我没有把标注释成
1 line
English:
请阅读图片说明
注意图片中无关内容勿喷
在图片上画一个框
而是把它看成一套训练数据生产系统
当前系统里
数据集不是一个普通文件夹
1 line
在图像中找不到相关文字。
它包含图片、类别、标注、数据划分、统计信息以及导出能力
标注类型上
当前支持位测框、分割标注、旋转框、图斤果的分
类，资杰标注
以及SAM辅助生成的多边形
文重要讲解边界
pose当前更多遍的是
标注、验证、YOLO导出和评估诊断链路
完整的训练闭环仍然需要谨慎推进
之间的数据契约是否一致
第二块呢
是训练任务系统
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a blank or heavily blurred screen with no discernible content. Therefore, no lines can be identified, and no text can be extracted from this image.
图片 96 类型 1
图片 13 类型 1
图片 88 类型 2
图片 92 类型 1
提供训练 简介
基于已有的知识模型提供训练，接受预览，适合大多数业务场景。
全量训练
全部参数参与训练，适合任意类型大规模深度训练场景。
agent-train-yolo/th.gt medical-pills detect 资源 yolo/th.gt CPU 下载点 52 / 80 0.87% 8月13日20:32
zhui_da
种 条图片 1个类别 800条 验证 20%
自动识别为 direct
这一季里
我一直强调一个观点
训练不是一次命令执行
它应该是可观察、可追踪、可复盘的任务
真实项目里训练
不只需要运行 yolo train
它还要知道是谁
在什么权限下启动了训练
使用了哪个数据集
是什么task type
选择了哪个权重
参数是什么
日志里有没有错误
最终产物保存在哪里
所以训练系统需要状态机、实时日志、指标记录、
失败诊断以及产物归档
当前系统支持
detect segment OBB classify的训练链路
启动前还会校验task type和权重族
但平台的作用不是让用户更快犯错
而是尽快把错误提前暴露出来
训练系统最重要的也
不是能不能启动命令
而是训练失败以后
能不能知道为什么失败
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text or graphics. Therefore, it is not possible to identify the number of lines or extract the text of any lines.
使用了什么配置
以及最终产物属于哪一次任务
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text or graphics. Therefore, it is not possible to identify the number of lines or extract the text of any lines.
第三块是模型管理导出和部署
zhui_da
帧 条图片 1个类别 800x 备注 验证集 22%
自动识别为 detect
请输入文本
LAST
ORDER
EXTERNAL
LAST
训练结束以后
创建单位信息
很多项目最后会变成一堆PT文件
创建导出任务
很难知道每个文件来自哪里
所以我把模型看成版本资产
而不是一个权重文件
一个模型版本应该关联
训练仕务、效据果、训练参效、核心指标、状态
备注、导出产物等等
当前系统支持模型版本管理
也支持ONNX导出
当然还支持TensorRT、还有OpenVINO
部署部分第一季讲了配置文件
版本校验
部署记录以及回滚思路
但它仍然是轻量的单机的
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text or graphics. Therefore, it is not possible to identify the number of lines or extract the text of any lines.
我没有把它做成
像K8S那种平台
也没有做复杂的设备管理和IoT运维
因为第一季的重点是先把模型从
一个训练产物变成可以管理、可以评估
可以导出并能够进入
交付和部署流程的工程资产
做完以后
我最大的体会是模型版本真正解决的不是权重文件怎么改名
而是训练、评估、导出和部署之间
能不能建立可追踪的关系
第四块是评估主动学习和迭代闭环
留言
创建账户信息
一定会不断遇到漏检、误检、低置信度、困难场景
所以系统必须能够
回答模型错在哪里
下一轮应该优先标哪些图片
当前主动学习
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a blank or partially obscured screen with no visible content. Therefore, no lines can be identified, and no text can be extracted from the image.
案例样本预览
也就是第十期的那句话
管理全职样本
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a blank or very low-resolution image with no discernible content. Therefore, no lines can be identified, and no text can be extracted from it.
视觉系统真正的闭环
不是训练任务显示了已完成
而是模型暴露的问题
能不能重新回到数据生产过程
第五块是agent智能体
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a blank or partially obscured screen with no visible content. Therefore, no lines can be identified, and no text can be extracted from the image.
当前采用的是轻量agent profiles
底层共享
Tool Router、Planner、Executor 以及 Tool Layer
不同profile拥有自己的页面上下文
Tool Allowlist和关注重点
agent的定位也很明确
agent负责调度
tool负责执行
人负责确认
呢其中
Tool Allowlist 控制当前
智能体能调用什么
RBAC控制当前用户执行什么
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a blank or partially obscured image with no discernible content. Therefore, no lines can be identified, and no text can be extracted from it.
高风险动作再通过人工确认完成门禁
例如 Dataset Agent 可以分析数据质量
Training Agent可以诊断训练失败
Model Agent 可以对比模型版本
Global Agent 可以汇总系统
状态并给出下一步建议
我最大的体会是
智能体必须建立在
业务能力已经工具化之后
如果数据集、训练、模型和王动字习这些模块还没有
稳定Tool
agent很容易变成一个知道很多概念
却不知道项目真实状态的聊天框
The image provided is completely black and contains no text. Therefore, there are no lines to identify.
很重要的主题AI CODING
在这个项目里面
我主要用了Stitch、Codex、Cursor
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text. Therefore, there are no lines to identify.
Stitch负责UI原型和视觉方向
Cursor适合日常开发
比如局部组件的修改
前后端联调、样式调整、bug修复
然后 Codex 更适合复杂的工程任务
比如模块设计、后端接口、数据结构、任务拆分
跨文件改造
但这里面还缺少一个最重要的角色人
人负责确定产品方向
架构边界、数据结构、项目规则
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text or graphics. Therefore, it is not possible to identify the number of lines or extract the text of any lines.
最终取舍以及验收的标准
所以我的体会是AI CODING
不是一个工具包打天下
Stitch更像设计助理
Cursor更像贴身的开发助理
Codex则更适合复杂的工程化任务
真正决定工程质量的
不是哪一个AI Coding工具更强
而是项目有没有清楚的数据结构
模块边界、验收标准和工程规范
否则AI写的越快
项目可能乱的越快
当然这一季做出的还
不是一个完美的平台
很多能力已经跑通
但仍然有
明确的MVP边界
已经跑通的包括数据集、多仕务称汪、仕务训练、模
型版本
模型导出、轻量部署、评估主动学习
轻量agent profile以及单租户的RBAC
当前的边界也很明确
系统目前主要还是单机模式
存储以Sqlite、MySQL和文件系统为主
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text. Therefore, there are no lines to identify.
训练还不是云训练或集群调度
部署中心不是完整的设备管理平台
主动学习还依赖人工复核
并不是线上数据全自动回流
不同视觉任务的闭环程度也不完全相同
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text. Therefore, there are no lines to identify.
detect、segment、obb的部分链路相对更加完整
pose等任务目前更侧重标注导出和评估诊断
RBAC当前解决了登录认证
固定角色权限码
前后端鉴权
以及用户管理
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text. Therefore, there are no lines to identify.
但还没有做多租户、project、dataset ACL
自定义的角色
企业SSO
而是第一季还没有必要一开始全部做进去
因为MVP不是把所有功能都做一半
而是用可控的复杂度
跑通最核心的业务闭环
先证明这个方向成立
再逐步增加系统的复杂度
如果这个项目重做一遍
如果觉了困难重做一遍
我会按照三个阶段推进
第一阶段先做业务底座
包括数据结构、标注系统和YOLO导出闭环
dataset、image、class、annotation 这些核
穴对象
视一定要先想清楚产力
而且YOLO导出应该尽早做
因为能不能稳定导出是检验数据集
系统设计是否合理的重要标准
第二阶段在做工程闭环
包括训练任务模型版本
评估部署和主动学习训练
系统从第一天就应该任务化
不要先写个按钮直接执行命令
后面再补状态机、日志和失败处理
第三阶段再做智能编排
先把业务能力做成工具
视再接智能体
等这些能力稳定以后
后面再做workflow和编排器
智能体不要太早接力
如果工具还不稳定
智能体只能变成个花哨的聊天框
workflow也不要过早复杂化
流程编排应该建立
在数据集、训练模型
主动学习和智能体都比较稳定以后
还有一个很重要的判断标准
不要先追求功能数量
要先确认每个模块产生的数据
能不能被下个模块稳定消费
如果重做一次生产力
我仍然会坚持这个顺序
先做业务闭环
生产力
再做智能调度主生产力
最后做流程编排
产力
如果继续做第三季
我不会一次性把所有方向全部铺开
我会围绕四条主线
第一条是生产力
视觉工程系统才是生产力
数据智能第一季已经完成了SAM辅助标注
和主动学习的第版
第二季会继续探索数据质量评估
更智能的自动与半自动标注
主动学习能力增强以及YOLO World
LocateAnything这些开放词汇
检测和视觉定位能力
第季解决的是产力
数据能不能进入系统
第二季要解决哪些数据更有价值
哪些数据应该优先标
以及如何进步降低人工标注成本
第二条主线是边缘部署
模型训练出来以后不是
只跑在开发机或者服务器上
真实的项目里
生产力
它可能要跑在英伟达的Jetson
RK3588 统算能 产力
英特尔CPU或NPU
以及更边缘的设备上
这会带来系列问题
模型格式怎么选择
推理引擎怎么适配
FP16 INT8怎么评估
不同芯片的速度和精度怎么对比
部署失败以后怎么诊断
第二季会继续把模型
视觉工程系统才是生产力
从可以导出推进到力
可以面向具体硬件落地
第三条主线是多模态的视觉
YOLO 更擅长检测、分割、分类
这些结构化视觉任务
但很多场景里
生产力
用户不只是想知道目标在哪里
还想知道这张图有什么异常
这个缺陷可能什么原因
这批错误样本有什么共性
能不能用自然语言解释检测结果
所以第二季会探索VLM怎么和YOLO结合
YOLO负责结构化感知
VLM负责语义理解、解释和辅助决策
第四条主线是工程自动化
第一季把数据集、训练、模型部署主动
学习和agent这些模块做出来以后
第二季可以继续思考这些能力
能不能被编排成可复用可暂停
可重试并且带人工门槛的流程
视觉工程系统才是生产力
链路数据回流生产力
视觉样本筛选是生产力
视觉人工复核是生产力
视觉重新训练是生产力
视觉评估对比是生产力
视觉生成报告是生产力
第一季是从功能点走到功能闭环
第二季要继续从功能闭环走向
流程闭环和真实场景落地
所以这季我们从个
视觉工程系统才是生产力
很简单的问题开始
为什么YOLO不只是行命令
The image provided is completely black and does not contain any text or graphics. Therefore, it is not possible to identify the number of lines or extract the text of any lines.
YOLO 提供的核心训练入口
可以被压缩成一行命令
但真正让它在项目里面持续
产生价值的是一套工程系统
数据集系统决定数据能不能管理
标注系统决定训练
数据能不能稳定生产
训练任务系统决定
训练能不能追踪和复盘
模型管理决定权重
能不能变成版本资产
导出和部署决定
模型能不能进入真实的业务流程
评估和主动学习要决定模型
错误能不能推动下一轮迭代
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a blank or partially obscured image with no discernible content. Therefore, no lines can be identified, and no text can be extracted from it.
agent决定系统能不能基于真实
数据和工具帮助人更快完成判断
而是逐步确认每个模块产生
的数据能不能被下一个模块稳定消费
第一季真正做的
不是把所有功能都做到最深
而是用可控的复杂度先跑通一个
视觉工程闭环
最后用一句话总结第一季
YOLO是起点
The image provided is too blurry to accurately recognize any text. It appears to be a blank or partially obscured screen with no visible content. Therefore, no lines can be identified, and no text can be extracted from the image.
视觉工程系统才是生产力